this is closer to the Bone uh because uh
John is uh very much
involved in the central situation that's
going on he can save you is that your
concern saving me there are other
victims of these Crooks thieves Liars
scammers criminals who with those 34
people to you John case was different
did you heal any of those 34 people JN
is way closer
to what's happening in Saw X than he has
ever been before Tobin Bell is a hero of
mine I flipp and love that guy so much
he is so smart about the character of
John Kramer which he is the the premier
expert on WE pitched the movie to to
Tobin before we set out to do it and he
loved the idea and he he actually
embellished and and brought us a bunch
of stuff to the to the script and then
as every Saw movie Tobin pretty much
writes his own
dialogue